أعلن كيم جونغ أون انتصار
بلاده على covet 19 وفقًا لوسائل الإعلام الحكومية ،
وهو ادعاء لا يمكن لـ CNN التحقق منه ، لكنه
جاء وسط تقارير تفيد بأن الزعيم
نفسه
عانى بشدة من حمى شديدة
أثناء تفشي المرض ، والآن
تدعو أخته إلى الانتقام المميت
ضده.  كوريا الجنوبية لنشر
الفيروس شمالًا لمزيد من المعلومات ، انضممت إلى سي إن إن
بولا هانكوك ، إنها تعيش من أجلنا في سيول
كوريا الجنوبية باولا رائعة لرؤيتك ، فما
وراء إعلان النصر هذا حقًا من قبل
الشمال وأنا أشعر بالفضول إذا كان هناك
حقًا  تم تنفيذ الانتقام ضد
كوريا الجنوبية أو كان ذلك مجرد تهديد
حسنًا ، ومن المؤكد أنه يُنظر إليه على أنه
انتصار من وجهة نظر كيم جونغ أون
من وجهة نظر أه النخبة في كوريا الشمالية
أه ولكن بالطبع هناك
أسئلة حول ما إذا كان  أو لا يمكن لدولة
مثل كوريا الشمالية أو أي دولة أن
تقضي فعليًا على الفيروس السري في
غضون 91 يومًا ، كانت هناك
أسئلة عندما قالوا إنه لا توجد
حالات سرية هناك الآن
المزيد  الاستفسارات الآن يقولون أه لقد
تغلبوا على الفيروس ولكن الأمر يتعلق أكثر
بالمراسلة نفسها حقيقة أن كيم
جونغ أون يريد أن يخبر شعبه
أن الوقت قد حان للمضي قدمًا وأنه من الواضح أنه
مستعد للمضي قدمًا أيضًا ، فلنستمع  في
جزء من خطابه ،
انتهت الحرب الصعبة ضد المرض
الآن واليوم
[تصفيق]
عن إصابة شقيقها بحمى شديدة
أيضًا ويمكنك أن ترى من
بعض الصور في وسائل الإعلام الحكومية
بعض الجمهور
أصبحت النخبة عاطفية لأنها كانت تتحدث
عن أن لديها أيضًا رسالة أقوى بكثير
لإعطاء كوريا الجنوبية شيئًا
انتقدته بالفعل
لكوريا الجنوبية في الأشهر الأخيرة ، لكنها ألقت باللوم
على الجنوب في البدء بفعالية
ونقل الوباء
إلى الشمال.  إلقاء اللوم على
بالونات الهواء الساخن هذه التي أرسلها بعض
النشطاء الكوريين الشماليين السابقين أو السابقين
عبر الحدود حاملين
أشياء مثل الدعاية المعادية لكوريا الشمالية
أيضًا أشياء مثل الأقنعة وأقراص فيتامين ج.
نانوغرام أن هذه هي الطريقة التي وصل بها
الفيروس إلى البلاد الآن أه
قال الجانب الكوري الجنوبي إنهم نادمون على
هذا النوع من الاتهامات وأه
لا يصدقون أن هذه هي الطريقة التي بدأ بها ولكن
كيم جونغ أون يقول إنه يمكن أن يكون
هناك انتقام مميت ضد  كوريا الجنوبية
إذا استمروا في محاولة إرسال
الفيروس عبر الحدود
لك